JERZY FORYCIARZ: Welcome.
My name is Jerzy Foryciarz, and
I'm a Product Manager on GKE.
With me on the virtual stage,
Joel Meyer, Chief Architect
at OpenX, and Ivan
Gusev, Principal
Infrastructure Architect at
OpenX In the next 25 minutes
we will show you how OpenX
looks at performance and cost,
how to become a hero
metering and understanding
your utilization on GKE, how
to optimize for what you need,
and then, what does
it mean in practice?
So let's get started.
When we talk about cost
performance optimization on GKE
we mentioned two
dimensions for a reason.
While the ultimate
amount of your spend
on the infrastructure depends
on the provisioned resources,
it is important to
understand your application,
how it operates,
and what you expect
from the service it represents.
So is your application
stateless or stateful?
Is it serving or
data processing?
How long does it take to start
from deployment to active,
and how much time
does it need to drain?
So a second factor, expected SLO
of service you are providing.
What is the latency of the
service that you expect?
Can you afford longer start up
time if this means lower cost?
Do you need to provision
for high availability?
How does it impact the
choice of machine types
and the level of
overprovisioning?
So how do you do
this in practice?
Let's hear the life story
from Joel and Ivan from OpenX.
JOEL MEYER: Thanks, Jerzy.
So these numbers represent
OpenX in a nutshell
prior to our migration.
We were a hundred
billion requests per day.
We're running 15
million lines of code,
deployed on 15,000 servers
around the globe in five
different regions.
Now OpenX is an ad exchange.
And so those billions
of ad requests
are coming from a
multitude of clients
with an SLA of between
150 to 400 milliseconds,
depending on the client.
And we call the set
of services that
handle those requests
the delivery system,
and that comprises about half
of our infrastructure cost.
So as you can see from the load
balancer stance on the screen,
we have both a daily pattern
with peaks and troughs,
and then a weekly pattern
as well, with lower traffic
on weekends and then
higher during the week.
Prior to migration, we had
pretty traditional deployment
strategy.
Services were packaged
as RPMs and they
were deployed via SaltStack
on physical hardware.
But we felt that being on prem
was limiting our efficiency.
So when we moved to
the Cloud, our goal
was to modernize for the
purposes of gaining efficiency,
scalability, and consistency.
And we felt that Kubernetes
was the right answer for that,
but we also knew we didn't
want to be running Kubernetes
ourselves.
So when we evaluated
the different offerings
from the competitors, it
seemed like GKE was probably
about two years ahead
of everybody else,
both in terms of
features and stability.
Now, early on, Ivan had
looked at the CPU utilization
of all of our services,
both at peak and on average,
to get a sense of
how much compute
we'd actually need in the cloud.
And what he found was
pretty interesting.
So the x-axis here
is peak utilization,
and the y-axis is
average utilization.
Now, in an on-prem environment,
your server count's fixed,
so unless your service is
running at full tilt all day
long, off peak is
basically wasted compute.
And with our diurnal traffic
pattern and our weekend
patterns, we had a
lot of wasted compute.
The graph also
illustrated for us
that we could save
significantly on compute cost
if we could buy only what
we needed throughout the day
and could share hardware
with auxiliary services.
Now, keep in mind
that this is only one
dimension of CPU utilization.
We're not looking
at memory or I/O.
Those aren't captured, either.
And that's why some of the
numbers may look a little sad.
So the services circled there,
those are the delivery system.
And we knew that these were
the candidates for GKE,
and that moving to
GKE would enable
us to scale compute based on
our traffic patterns and needs,
and also to gain efficiency
by optimal packing
of the services on hardware.
Let's take a brief look at
some of the before and after.
So on-prem, services
were rarely restarted.
You would deploy
and you would start,
and it would run unless
there was a problem.
Also they didn't grow
and shrink in number.
Whereas in the cloud, the
pods were very dynamic,
spinning up, spinning down.
And also the cluster size was
dynamic, growing or shrinking.
So we're going from a
very static environment
to a very dynamic environment.
And that's what we
wanted, but it also
introduced some
challenges for us.
A few other differences
worth noting.
On-prem, hardware is
dedicated to a service.
And as a result,
that service was
tuned for maximum
utilization of that server,
whereas in the cloud
you're optimizing
your pod for the resources
that you've allocated to it.
And then you're
optimizing your cluster
for overall utilization.
So what that means
practically speaking is
we weren't just migrating from
one containerized environment
to another.
We were moving from a
very server-based model
to a completely unoptimized
container model,
and that added a
lot of complexity.
But what it did mean
is that we could
go from using the fewest servers
possible at peak to a world
where we could provision only
what we needed at any given
time, and that was our
definition of victory.
So we had an idea of what
was technically possible
in Kubernetes.
But we still needed to translate
that into a cost model.
And to accomplish that, Ivan did
some pretty extensive modeling.
There were a couple
dimensions to that.
First, he modeled the type
of compute that we would use.
Would we be using on
demand, or could we
benefit from a commitment
and use committed use?
Or most cost effectively,
could we use preemptable nodes?
Second, he translated compute to
hosted services in some cases.
Rather than running
[? ReactKB ?] on PBMs,
we decided, let's take
advantage of Bigtable.
Let's take advantage of
LB, of Load Balancing.
And, finally, he
adjusted the amount
based on our actual utilization.
So that model gave us a good
idea of what we could get to.
Actually getting to
that target efficiency
is the journey that we'd
like to share with you.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Before we go
on the journey of autoscaling,
let's recap what
we're dealing with.
In Kubernetes, there are
two layers of abstraction,
the workload layer where
you deploy your pods,
and the cluster layer,
where you deal with nodes.
Google Kubernetes Engine
provides automation
at both of these layers so that
your service works optimally
all the time.
The Horizontal Pod
Autoscaler, or HPA,
is adding and removing
pods at the same time
based on the utilization
metrics, which
can be CPU utilization,
or custom metrics,
like requests per second
or number of tasks
in a pub/sub queue.
This solves for the
cases where more requests
call for more machines,
which would be likely
the case of your serving front
end, application back end,
or pull off processing workers.
But what if the amount of
memory or CPU is not appropriate
for your process, or your system
cannot scale by adding more
machines easily?
Take a database or file
system as an example.
This is where Vertical Pod
Autoscaler comes to rescue.
It is monitoring the
resource utilization
and allows for adjusting
the pod requests
to either improve performance
or reduce unused resources.
Similarly, on the
infrastructure layer,
Cluster Autoscaler
automatically adds and removes
nodes in the cluster.
This operation
happens in response
to pending pod requests
by the scheduler and CPU
utilization of the node.
Node autoprovisioning decides
on the type of node pools
on your behalf automatically.
This way, Cluster
Autoscaler can always
keep the most optimal,
meaning cheapest,
configuration of your cluster.
So in summary, GKE is
offering four dimensions
of autoscaling to help you
optimize cost and performance
of your workloads.
So how did OpenX use them
to optimize for cost?
IVAN GUSEV: Thank you, Jerzy.
Glad to be here.
Horizontal Pod Autoscalers
allow each deployment
to scale independently
while maintaining each pod
workload at nearly concentrate.
This significantly reduces the
number of performance scenarios
that need to be tested
and optimized for.
We found that for
most workloads,
CPU utilization targets work
best as changes in code,
often changing
execution efficiency,
and would need to be
constantly adjusted
if a custom metric is used.
As a global company,
we also [? served ?]
regional differences in
the coded [INAUDIBLE] pass.
This can significantly
complicate application rating
for particular workload volumes.
Custom metrics are still
useful if your workload is not
CPU bound, but rather
I/O or network bound.
Remember, Kubernetes does
not give you explicit choice
over pod division process.
When deployment is
scaled down, Kubernetes
observes pod disruption budget
while randomly selecting a pod
to scale down.
This creates imbalance
in utilization of nodes.
Cluster Autoscaler
normally takes
care of underutilized nodes.
If you need an
additional control,
you can use the
scheduler, an open source
project helping to balance
resource utilization of nodes.
When a cluster has one
or more pods ending,
the cluster Autoscaler
kicks in and determines
what node pools can and
should increase in size
to accommodate these workloads.
To choose the best
option, it considers
fitness of each
node configuration
to accommodate pending pods.
In other words, how well
particular node size will match
pods that need to be scheduled.
It also takes into account an
estimated cost of cluster size
increase and will account
to increase multiple node
pools sequentially.
So some kind of [? fold ?] or
[? stock ?] out can then be
detected.
At OpenX we started with
very prescriptive model
when we defined exactly
what node pool will
host each workload.
However, that often
meant that there is only
one application pod per node.
When we allow the Cluster
Autoscaler to choose the best
node pool dynamically,
we found that
provisioned virtual machines
match our workloads much more
closely, which use less memory
and less CPU, [? based ?] less.
GKE also offers fast scale down
cluster of the Scaler profile,
which removes underutilized
nodes much more rapidly,
thus lowering the cost
of your cluster faster.
Joel, back to you.
JOEL MEYER: Thanks, Ivan.
So Ivan just
described the benefits
of the Horizontal Pod Autoscaler
and the Cluster Autoscaling.
Once we had implemented
both of those,
our compute usage began to
follow our traffic patterns,
both the diurnal daily pattern
and the weekly pattern, which
you can see on the slide there.
That's the beauty
of Autoscaling.
When it's enabled at
the application layer
and at the hardware
layer, it translates
into cost efficiency.
Let's take a brief side journey
to talk about measurement.
So optimization
without measurement
is nearly impossible.
You need visibility
into your starting point
and where your resources
are being consumed.
So you need the ability
to measure improvement.
You want to understand
your pod utilization,
how are they performing.
You want to understand
your node utilization,
how many are being used
and to what extent.
You also need to understand
your overall cost,
because at the end of the
day, that's what matters.
But really, you'd love
to measure everything,
and we used a combination
of different tools
to accomplish that.
First, we used
Prometheus and Grafana
to measure service metrics
and application metrics.
All our services
were instrumented,
and Kubernetes offers those
metrics out of the box,
as well.
Then we also used BigQuery
to track the cost metrics
that GCP makes available.
And there's an
entire separate talk
on that topic, which we
encourage you to check out.
And then finally, we use
the GKE Metering Dashboard
to see which services
were consuming
the most resources and cost.
When it comes to
optimization, your destination
is the model you've created,
and measurement is your GPS.
It tells you how far
you've come and also
how far you've got to go.
Let's talk about some
of the next stops
on our optimization journey.
IVAN GUSEV: Sure.
With HPA and cluster
Autoscaling configured,
we next looked at
pod optimization.
For the average case,
pod tuning is a matter
of making sure you understand
ratio of RAM and CPU
needed for the application to
operate at certain throughput.
Then you just set requests
and limits accordingly.
In some cases, you may also need
to tune underlying technology,
like JVM, if needed.
If your pod isn't utilizing
the requested resources,
you can reduce the request,
which will release the capacity
back to the cluster.
If your pod's consistently
over utilizing
the requested
resources, then you
may need to increase
the request in order
to improve service continuity.
Here you see Auto
Memory Killer in action.
GKE provides Vertical
Pod Autoscaler
that watches your pod
resource utilization
and recommends pod sizes.
It is an automated way of
process that we used at OpenX.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Vertical Pod
Autoscaling does three things.
It watches the resource
usage by the selected pods.
After it collects enough data,
it provides recommendations
to what should be the
actual resource should
be specified in the pod spec.
And then, if enabled, it
applies the recommendation
to selected pods.
You can apply the
recommendations yourself,
similarly to what OpenX
did with their workloads.
You can also enable automatic
activation of your pods
according to the
recommendations.
This can happen in two
ways, at pod creation time
or continuously.
JOEL MEYER: The
VPA recommendations
that Jerzy just described
are incredibly useful.
And another GKE
feature that enabled
us to optimize performance
was CPU Manager,
which Ivan is going to tell
us a little bit more about.
IVAN GUSEV: Sure.
Just like the noisy neighbor
effect on virtual machines,
a similar effect
exists for pods.
Sometimes that's by design,
to achieve overall higher
virtual machine utilization.
However, OpenX runs a large
number of applications
written in Erlang.
And Erlang virtual machine
has its own schedule
of threads which work
most efficiently if they
run on the same CPU core all
the time and aren't swapped out
or competing for CPU
with other applications.
For scenarios like
this, Kubernetes
has a feature
called CPU Manager.
It provides additional
guarantees of CPU allocation
on top of what Kubernetes
resource requests are already
doing.
While resource requests are only
used by Kubernetes Scheduler
to make important decisions
on where to schedule pods,
the CPU Manager enforces
CPU allocation to the pod,
continuously prohibiting
all other pods
from stepping into CPU
managed pod territory
and minimizing the number
of contact switches.
The flip side of CPU Manager
is that pod cannot exceed
their requests and efficiently
sandboxed in terms of CPU
capacity.
For our Erlang systems,
that's exactly what we wanted.
Joel?
JOEL MEYER: So with Autoscaling
enabled and our pods tuned,
we still needed to tackle
another area of optimization--
how do we make the most
use of a cluster that
has diverse set of
services running in it?
So in a nutshell, how do
we optimally bin pack?
There are two parts
to that challenge.
One, how do we size our
pods so that they're
more easily accessible?
And then two, how
do we size our nodes
so that they can accommodate
the right number of pods?
We have some control
over both dimensions,
so we needed to
find a sweet spot.
IVAN GUSEV: Kubernetes Scheduler
takes several pods' properties
into consideration to
make decision on what
node pod gets scheduled.
Two primary capacity
related fields
are resource requests,
or CPU and memory.
Kubernetes Scheduler does
not scale cluster up or down,
but rather works
with available nodes,
aiming to fit as
many pods as possible
into provision capacity.
And when this is not
possible and pods
are pending, Cluster Autoscaler
provisions more nodes.
Here's an example of CPU and
memory constrained nodes.
On the left graph, you can
see that even though only 78%
of CPU capacity is allocated,
no pods larger than 4 CPUs
can be scheduled.
Similarly, on high
CPU node scheduler,
node scheduler cannot add any
new pods because the single pod
has already allocated pretty
much all memory capacity.
So we ended up with CPU resource
utilization of just 28%.
How can this impact
inefficiency,
and can it be improved?
You can make all pods
equal size and make sure
that each node can
fit exactly n pods.
This is not always ideal, as
workload capacity requirements
and ability to scale
vertically differ a lot.
At OpenX, we use 2 to
the power of n rule.
We standardize pod sizes
on 1, 2, 4, and 16 cores.
This also matches
GCE standard VM sizes
and allows us to move
between different VM sizes
without a need to
optimize pod sizes again.
While doing so, make sure that
you account for space reserve
by Kubernetes for
daemon sets and kernel.
Also don't forget to pay
attention to your sidecar
and init containers, as their
resource requests might be
affecting scheduling decisions.
Generally speaking, you
will get best results
of bin packing when pod requests
are small fractions of CPUs
while nodes are
relatively large.
Yet if you're using
preemptable virtual machines,
you have to watch for losing
a large number of pods
in case of preemption.
Measuring the bin
packing efficiency
is quite simple, as you need to
aggregate all workflow resource
requests and divide
it by total capacity.
It can be tracked as a cluster
wide metric, or node pool
specific ratio.
We observe that Autoscaled
clusters with no pod size
optimizations we usually get
around 75% of CPU reserve,
while clusters with improved
bin packing efficiency
reach all the way to 95%.
Similar optimizations can be
done for memory dimension.
However, memory generally
requires significant headroom,
and usage is less predictable
compared to CPU cores.
Our memory reservations
are currently
measured at around 50%.
Optimization of bin packing
in more than one dimension
is totally possible, but
depending on your workload
profile, it may end up
exponentially harder
to implement with every
new dimension that you add.
We decided to leave this
exercise for the future.
Joel?
JOEL MEYER: Ivan.
So early on when we were
doing our Cloud cost modeling,
Ivan picked out
services that could
take advantage of
preemptable virtual machines.
And for the delivery stack,
we assume that roughly 70%
of our compute could
be preemptable Now
when we first tested,
we were discouraged
because it was hard to get
the PBM capacity we needed.
But after discussing
with the GCE team,
they encouraged us to try
a smaller sized PBM node.
After making that change,
we were much more successful
in finding the PBM
capacity, and we have even
exceeded our initial
target PBM utilization.
But it is another factor
to consider in bin packing.
So the GKE cluster
autoscaler allows
us to tap into
different PBM pools
by attempting to scale
up different node
pools sequentially.
That could be node pools
of different VM sizes,
or using different
compute families.
So while we've
presented our journey
as a nice linear
progression, the reality
was a bit more winding,
with some back and forth
between the different
optimization techniques.
That being said, the six
approaches we've discussed
are all worth looking into.
First, configure and tune your
Horizontal Pod Autoscalers.
Two, enable the
Cluster Autoscaler.
Three, rightsize
your pod requests
and/or use the Vertical
Pod Autoscaler.
Number four, use the CPU Manager
for the applications that
need that level of guarantee.
Number five, optimize
your bin packing.
And then, number six, find
the right machine type
for your workload.
So thanks to the work that
Ivan and the team have done,
we're now able to
run our GKE clusters
on a very small
set of node pools
that scale based on
price and availability.
And thanks to the
optimized pods,
the HPAs, the right
choices in machine sizes,
we've improved
efficiency by over 45%.
One of the things that was
invaluable to the success
of this project was the
ability to meet with and ask
questions of the different teams
whose technology we're using.
Whether that was Jerzy and
the GKE Autoscalers Team,
the CPU Manager
Team, the GCE Team,
or any one of the other
teams that we met with,
we were really impressed
by their willingness
to work with us and help
us use their technology.
We also took advantage
of the GCP PSO team
to help us in various
parts of the migration
and found their help to
be very valuable, as well.
Thank you, particularly,
to Will [? Beebee. ?]
So Jerzy, thanks for allowing
us to share some of our story
here with you.
And to the audience,
good luck with your own
optimization efforts.
Jerzy, back to you.
JERZY FORYCIARZ: Thank
you, Joel and Ivan,
for sharing your
experience with us.
For those of you willing to get
on a journey of optimizing cost
to performance on GKE, we just
published two solution guides
that will get you an advice
on best practices of running
cost effective
Kubernetes applications
and how to use node
autoprovisioning
to optimize your resources.
These guides are a collective
summary of experiences of OpenX
and many other companies who
shared their stories with us.
We will keep
updating it as we add
more functionality to
Google Kubernetes Engine.
You should also take a look
at related breakout sessions
airing this week.
On behalf of Google
Cloud Team, I
want to thank you for watching.